I am a very good test taker I'm a
terrible test taker I think I'm a pretty
fantastic test taker why do they have a
separate literacy test at understand is
it a racist thing
oh this test is to be given to anyone
who cannot prove a 5th grade education
one wrong answer denotes failure of the
test you have 10 minutes to complete
this test circle the first the first
first better the alphabet in this slide
why are there two firsts in the first
circle below right the last letter of
the first word beginning with the letter
L yeah that's where I'm like what why is
my head hurt cross out the number
necessary when making the number below 1
million but that doesn't what that
doesn't make sense to me this is a
literacy quiz draw a square with a
triangle in it within that same triangle
draw a circle with a black dot o so
loominatee I spelled backwards forwards
we gotta move faster any questions
Oh God Kellan is Gary cuz I didn't feel
really competitive right now like we
have to I'm dead I'm just giving up oh
this is hard we got to question 25 I
would not be able to vote I went either
failed hardcore because I didn't even
complete the test I know that this test
was intentionally trying to trick me and
it succeeded and that makes me really
really sad the efforts to go to like
make discrimination official it blows my
mind to be a black person to have the
right to vote you have to literally get
through [ __ ] riddles it made me
realize that I take voting for granted
it makes me appreciate it more to me it
would actually have the right to vote
your duty almost as an American citizen
to vote
this is I open to me in a different
light because in Puerto Rico right now
we're a country of United States
citizens and because we're a territory
we can't vote I just think that we found
new ways to suppress voting lengths in
certain states where there's only three
or four places where you can register to
vote and they're miles and miles away
from counties that have a predominantly
poor
demographic
but makes me more upset is just knowing
that there's no like concrete answers a
person who is administering the test is
the one who determines if it's right
yeah this just proves that black people
should never say they want to go back in
time there's just nothing better back
there